the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
alright hey you know the drill from the
previous couple of weeks get your piece
of paper out and write down what you
think we're important concepts for the
last week or so okay let's see what you
have on your papers Kristin okay so sit
the center of the concept of center of
mass and things you can use it for so
I'm going to generalize that to systems
of particles and your tell you what
you've just said is center of mass is
one thing that comes from that anybody
on this subject of systems of particles
anybody else have something angular
momentum so what about it yeah so this
concept of the summation of the H is
right equal to kind of H of the system
and that you can use that okay anything
else about systems particles that we've
that you learn
yeah Newton's third law and I helped us
work things out and had a consequence
you found center of mass that's useful
but you take the derivative of the
center of mass what what do you find out
our G here dot times the total mass is
what yeah its momentum but it's momentum
of what well it's the momentum of the
entire system right and so this is the
summation of the pis that's kind of
important and finally take another
derivative what's that would you learn
about that pardon what kind of forces
all of the external forces on the system
all of them all of them so powerful
things came out of it and thinking about
center of mass okay all right what is
something else said during the week that
wasn't around systems of particles yes
actually shout out give me your say your
name when you're what I call on you I'm
gonna try to learn more of your name
Christina right so when you're looking
at
for devil like before
looking at what pieces go where so if
you have a look into five
okay and I put that in the category of
free bot free body diagrams are you
thinking of so constructing free body
diagrams okay what else
Eddie Eddie yeah okay the two different
mothers for finding work yeah
so let's go a little further with torque
what do you use the torque for and what
do you want to find tort for to get
alright let's generalize this to equate
the motion so both in for forces and
moments two different kinds of problems
if we are able to do by being able to
find the torques okay anything else
it's important this week that's it
yeah I mean this is an amount for some
yeah you got to be able to solve
differential equations but yeah maybe
you're you're actually onto something
here but let's put it in the context of
what kind of equations that we work on a
lot on this week
what kind of equations of motion I don't
mean like second order linear do we're
doing dynamics we did dynamics if we
love what kind a lot of it acceleration
yeah but also we work a lot of examples
this week were they rotational problems
our translational problems all right
like kind of heavy emphasis this week on
angular momentum right so using okay
okay that's pretty good list my own list
had I only had most of that on him
I see more where my list was center of
mass R dot R double dot I wrote these
equations so this thing in particular
the summation of the external torques
with respect to some point for a
particle is dhdt
plus VA cross P and for we were just
beginning to do sums of collections of
particles and our rotating rigid bodies
where you have maybe more than one
particle the summation of the torques is
d H capital H now for the summation of
the H sub i's DT plus V a and O cross
and here's where we learn something up
here that you can do down here that was
really helpful
well cross with what which P
this one up here right and that's
actually this so this is cross P of the
center of mass of the system okay
good those are that's that's pretty good
list so now let's do let's do a problem
so here's the problem it's a rigid rod
with a mass on the end and the rods
massless just to make it easy for the
moment but this is now a rigid body okay
there's a torsional spring here Ana
torsional spring resists angular
displacement with a torque that's equal
to the spring constant times the theta
that you push it through okay so it
generates a moment a moment restoring
moment when you push it away it tries to
push this thing back gravity is also
acting so it's a pendulum with a rigid
as a rigid body and a torsional spring
so I want to first step I want you
eventually to find the equation of
motion and I want you to find do start
by doing a free body diagram but before
you go to work I'm going to give you a
little quick mini lecture on free body
diagrams so first thing you do is assign
coordinates maybe draw is not really
assign the coordinates for the problem
determine the number of degrees of
freedom we haven't talked about that
much yet it will become much more
important in the subject the number of
degrees of freedom but I'll say it once
then we'll do much more with this number
of degrees of freedom is the same thing
as the number of independent coordinates
you need to completely describe the
motion okay and the number of
independent coordinates that you need is
equal to the number of equations of
motion that you'll get
so this problem how many coordinates
does it take Denis so this is planar
motion it's confined to the board how
many actual coordinates does it take to
completely describe the position of this
thing I see a one about anybody else
what's the one what would you choose
yeah well what coordinate itself what is
the single coordinate you would use to
define the motion of the system I hear a
theta everybody agree theta of T if you
can figure out theta T you know this
position of this thing for all time
that's all you need one degree of
freedom one coordinate and in terms of
choosing the coordinate system to use
basically you were saying use what polar
polar coordinates centered here but
there's your inertial system but you're
going to go at this point this is our a
point and is it is it moving so if we
use expressions like this what will
happen to that term goes away right okay
nope
and we'll get to that and if I divert to
that I won't finish what I've got
planned for the day and it's important
and we're going to come back to that has
to do with constraints so you signed the
coordinates determine the number of
degrees of freedom assign positive
values to all rotations and
displacements velocities linear
velocities and rotational velocities in
the problem positive values of those and
from that you deduce the direction of
the resulting forces and moments and
this will help you get the signs correct
especially when you have multi body
problems like two masses with a spring
in between them which way to the forces
go on each mass all right okay so in
this problem there's only one coordinate
so we're really seeing a sign of
positive theta and assume a positive
theta dot what are the resulting forces
that end up in your Freebody diagram so
now I want you to write draw the
Freebody diagram for this thing and up
here final statement put in all forces
and moments don't don't leave out
anything because you know they're not
going to matter because it'll get you in
trouble as the problems get more
complicated okay draw your Freebody
diagrams okay so you're getting groups
of three or four and compare notes here
you guys are kind of a natural natural
group and you know can look check each
other stuff and come up with a come up
with a final alright so we were having a
debate about whether or not you were
asking us for the Freebody diagram of
the system or if you're asking us the
three by mentioning
well yeah so are there moments and
things involved up here like that store
tional spring when you are including the
entire system okay so this is a
rigidbody I kept saying this is a
rigidbody I happen to have a single mass
point in it but it's a whole single
rigid body and do the free body diagram
for the rigid body can you show me
something or you're at where are you
what's your best shot at this so far
spring forces so what what's the what's
your body that you're working with
that's the definition of the original
thinking about the particle but if
you're only thinking about the particles
kind of hard to get that torsional
spring involved so you need to think of
this is a sinkhole body one whole rigid
body and now draw you know just draw a
stick in here and put the forces on it
doesn't matter where the mass is for the
purpose of the free body diagram right
that comes into the
so you're getting into kind of the
equation of motion part of it is only
about assuming this thing has some
dynamic moment in time and draw the
external forces and moments that act on
the object the object is this
full-length stick okay so in that case
you just have the spring force acting in
opposition like I guess we can say it's
acting
Canada we have weights for sure you have
this spring puts it a moment on the
system and there are yet potential other
forces
I gave you a couple minutes because
there's a little confusion around
whether it's a particle or a rigid body
it's a rigid body you got to deal with
the whole body all right let's see what
you got
where's your where's your free body
diagram okay
so and tell me tell me what you have for
forces and moments just point to each
one of them and say what it is and so we
have the wake of this end and we assume
this is massless
yep minutes rigid so it's all one system
now I have one video so the center of
mass is right here because there's and
then we have reaction force movement and
then we have the moments in the spring
there okay all right yeah we we have
some sort of balls well yeah so you
can't convince one another who's right
here so if so that's why there is a
little system as there's a rubric that I
so I recommend you just use the system
this is basically a system for getting
equations of motion and this is
important that one so then if you know
it's positive then you can figure out
which direction the reaction is all
right I hate stopping all the fun you
guys are doing well there's school there
is great value in talking to one another
and convincing one another of what the
right way to do something is you know
you'll have two different points of view
and talking it out it's amazing how fast
you can make progress
so do that do that when you're home
doing solving problems so let's what was
the assignment here find the draw
Freebody diagram
well let's do it so it's a rigid body
all one body even though the mass is all
concentrated down here the forces what
are forces that are on this thing
give me one weight mg right okay what
else
normal force we're okay so you're
talking about a reaction force up here
and if you chosen a coordinate system we
already kind of decided didn't we on
polar coordinates for this right so our
the reaction force is known to start
with no so what's a what's the cleverest
way to assign them on your Freebody
diagram
well in Latin and associated with your
the coordinates right so I would I which
I would have two reaction forces up here
one in which one in each of which
directions radial n okay and the
positive radio positive tangential like
that right so I would say well I have an
unknown F theta force and I have an
unknown F R force and I draw them in
their positive directions because I have
no clue so it didn't make them positive
your assumed direction for them forces
here G there what about the tension on
the tension in the string does it belong
in this problem why not
the rigidbody it's an internal force
it's a little F IJ f ji thing it's those
things that cancel internally right so
you don't have to deal with it it's not
an external force to the rigidbody so
this is great
we want to find in the next step in this
is to find an equation of motion got to
be speedy about this
so what pardon
mama you use moment to do it
about what point all right so we call
that a you use angular momentum and
torques and that sort of thing is that
what you're seeing moments about it okay
no I gotta have your do it yourself do
it
so now sitting right guys oh we forget
that one so which direction is it
clockwise you're kind of fun all right
so there's a moment about this point
that is we know what it is it's in that
direction it has value KT times hey
anytime you know what it is right don't
do it make it an unknown write it out
you know it's that and you know it's in
this direction okay and we're going to
write how many equations of motion what
we get and we've chosen polar
coordinates you could write you could do
this in using forces just Newton's
second law but then you have to solve
for what if you write a for if you write
force balance F equals MA you have two
these appear and you don't know them so
the reason to use torques in this
problem is because are these going to
appear in your answer no so that's the
reason to use torture so something yeah
this is case of T to distinguish it as a
torsional spring no no it doesn't have
an Alice right here
it's a spring who gives a moment
resistance to being deflected it has kt
theta is units of torque
this isn't units of force per unit
displacement this is units of torque per
Radian okay yeah
well you have signed polar coordinates
and my assumption was that I drew it
right here there's positive theta hat
right yeah but yeah I've draw that it's
negative is accounted for by the sign by
the direction of the arrow
so let's now write the equation of
motion and to do the equation of motion
you're going to say that the sum of the
what external torques about what point a
is equal to D and I'll use the capital H
because we're now working our way on the
rigid bodies could have more than one
point we could have more than one mass
point the HDP plus V a cross P and
what's that in this problem that guy
conveniently is zero so do it you can
now do this problem figure out write
down an equation of motion using sum of
external torques and so you're gonna
have to figure out an angular momentum
and some tours okay
I hate pulling you guys away and lots of
there's lots of good thinking going on
alright drag yourselves away help me out
here which groups figured out that the
external torques okay what do you got
tell me what to do here tell me what it
is I want to write the drums down minus
M G L sine theta and what direction yeah
okay others agree with that term the
waves I can just have one sort I'm here
it's a gravity term we have a sign
correct then we have the moment arm
correct so it so this is the moment arm
our cross force looks like minus K to me
mg L sine theta looks pretty good how
what other torques moment from the
spring okay and tell me how to write
that
well compares the KT KT theta also K hat
direction and our free body diagram the
forces produce moments okay it's
everybody happy with that are we done
any questions about it appliances
mutilated okay
we're going to now we need this piece of
it so what's an H for rigid body the
summation of all the bits how many bits
are there just the one and that's our
cross a P can somebody tell me what they
got for the P is the momentum of our
little mass here with respect to an
inertial frame which is also a because
it stopped moving and R is L so this is
L R at cross M what L theta dot is its
velocity mass times velocity and its
direction theta hat R cross theta is K
so this looks like M l squared theta dot
k hat we all agreement dhdt
this k change direction so there's only
only time-dependent thing oh thank you
we're going to need that all right the
derivative is
okay that's equal to that it's all K's
you get just one equation out of this
you don't have to break it down into
subcomponents and you can collect it all
on one side M L squared theta double dot
plus K T theta plus M G L sine theta
equals zero and that's a second order
nonlinear ordinary differential equation
which you could linearize for small
motion and just a pendulum okay good we
got one other one I want to do before
the hour is out I got a big piece of
cement pipe on the back of a truck it's
not tied down the trucks move into three
meters per second okay
and the rotation rate of this piece of
pipe is 6 radians per second and the
trucks accelerating minus a half a meter
per second squared it's actually
breaking okay the guy's in trouble right
so the first thing here is Omega is 6
radians per second does it matter with
respect to what the truck or the ground
I haven't told you
talk in your groups and give me a quick
answer to that
what do you think
say again sir Kristen thinks it doesn't
matter anybody want to encounter that
why not
so you're saying that this could be a
Megan with respect to the truck or could
be mega with respect to this fixed frame
and the answer will be the same in
either case Christine right okay
Christina all right
but you had to know what this one like
it was with respect to what because this
will enormous for a teeny so-and-so with
this you have your one XY coordinate
system and while the chocolate is
translating the truck stop in any
rotation right so it's stayin in the
same chord
so your argument is if you were standing
on the ground seeing it rotating you'd
say seeing it you would see it rotate is
the same rate as if you're writing on
the truck everybody agree with that does
it matter that the truck's accelerating
right thing no
so only whether or not the trucks
rotating is the trucks not rotating then
rotation rates seen from this frame or
just a translating frame will always
seem the same even if it's that you're
accelerating okay so we've done that one
now I want you to find the velocity of
point G given this information so whip
it down quickly how you would approach
this problem see if you can solve it G
is the center of mass of that big pipe
okay we're going to running out of time
let's uh who's got an answer for me I
think they've got it sorted out Kristin
all right so let's uh be systematic so
you do it you have to pick some points
and do did you use a rotating frame you
use equation that requires a rotating
reference frame so I assume though
you're talking about this is we're
looking at the velocity of G and O is
equal to in general the velocity of some
point a that you're going to have to
pick plus velocity of G with respect to
a and this this thing has two possible
components right one which is the
derivative of G a DT ignoring the
rotation plus
okay it's what's this term in this
problem well we haven't picked a point a
we're going to pick point a there's dump
points and there's good points
what put front of the truck well it's
possible Christina what do you think yes
you had it yeah the point of contact is
that you're saying
anybody else what do you vote for where
do you want to put a point of contact
okay if you're using this equation and
you're using these pieces you are using
the concept of a rotating frame if
there's any Omega in the problem you
better have a rotating frame somewhere
right unless you use in polar
coordinates which is sort of a
degenerate rotating frame so if we at
this point we're going to make a here
and you have a coordinate system little
x1 y1 and attached to a so you have an
ax 1 y 1 here Z 1 and is it rotating is
it a rotating coordinate system well if
it's not then you can't do this you have
to this assumes this term here is the
the velocity at which this point in this
point are moving relative to one another
as if you were sitting on the pipe was
ignoring the you could you know you
don't see the rotation you're moving
with the pipe is the and the pipe had
better it's assuming you have then put a
reference frame on the pipe that moves
with the pipe so it is a little efforts
frame reference frame a XYZ move with
the pipe it better or you can't use the
equation so this this is attached to the
pipe and as it rolls it that you have to
allow that XYZ frame to move with it
okay
so in that frame what's this term
this is zero because the two points are
fixed on the in the pipe okay and what's
this velocity three meters per second in
the what direction do it in the inertial
frames we want okay and then what's this
term so it's six and we said doesn't
matter what frame it is it's all the
same rotation rate radians per second in
the what direction K hat cross the
radius is capital R with this direction
and now this is at an instant in time at
this particular instant in time you've
cleverly drawn the XYZ system so it
lines up with the master one so it makes
the problem easy so at the moment it's
either in the big J hat or in the little
J hat it's easiest if you do it in big
call it big Jake is in there you're done
so K cross J I think negative I and so
this should work out to be three meters
per second positive I one and a half
times six is nine and a - nine meters
per second in the negative mine and the
I direction right so you are at minus
six meters per second
wouldn't it be what matters a lot you
have to you have to exercise great care
when you pick the R vector and the R
vector goes from your origin to the
point you're talking about so the origin
that's your frame and that's the point
and then you draw the arrow the R vector
it goes from A to G that's its direction
and it has you know it's linked its link
capital R long yep that's that's a
really important point you know in which
way the arrows would go okay and so now
we're done with that and I see we've got
a minute or two let's talk about the
acceleration let's do the acceleration
of this problem acceleration of G in O
and this is just an exercise in
remembering the terms full 3d vector
equation for accelerations what's the
what's the first term here how about
before we even get into the end we're
not in polar coordinates in this all
right let's just work it out I start
with this one myself acceleration of a
with respect to O what's another term so
acceleration of G with respect to a but
no rotation right that term Plus how
many more terms do we have to go three
okay won't give me one somebody else
what's your name
Steven you've got a 2 Omega and Omega is
let's get it's unit vector in here well
actually it's not 2 Omega cross R let's
just do that ok that's ok what that
what's give me another term somebody
else
Omega cross Omega cross R and got
another one yeah and in fact we better
be a little more careful than that so
it's really the velocity of G with
respect to a and is it have rotation in
it or not this is the no rotation this
is the speed at which the points are
moving apart from one another right
Omega cross R cross R we got one two I
think we need another term Omega dot
cross R and they are is RG a this R is G
a okay so what's the velocity what's the
acceleration of this nope so this one's
minus 1/2 what's the it's this one so
this is your you're in the frame of the
pipe now and this is a speed at which
acceleration of G with respect to the a
ok it doesn't move it's fixed length
right this one what's the velocity of G
with respect to a without rotation and
involved okay this one is Omega K cross
and this is our again Omega K cross and
this RG is are in the what direction at
this instant J right so we could work
that out and what about this one what
direction is omega dot in okay cross r
at this instant j again okay do we know
that value no we have to deal with that
might be something a figure out so we
could you could now crank this out that
would be the acceleration of that point
but you'd find out that hmm we don't
have that now how would you go about
finding out what Omega dot is you get
the Goldstar equations of motion you
need to come up with equations of motion
and how many how many equations of
motion would we end up writing this is
equivalent asking how many degrees of
freedom are there okay I hear - I hear a
1 so how many now now so this it there's
a lot of nuances to this this discussion
anytime something is you're given a
fixed value for something that that
coordinate is constrained at parameters
constrain the were given the motion of
the truck it's completely specified
the you'll just you can just substitute
numbers in for those things I mean like
this it pops up as 1/2 okay
the I think this thing will boil down to
one equation and you need to pick some
set of coordinates to describe it so I
would probably if I'm looking for a mega
dot I'd probably work with torque about
that point some of the torques on 10
makes it I salute it to just this object
and it's the sum of the torques around
this point and see what happens
it's got to be equal to the sum of the
external torques got to equal to what
the HTT and then you have to sort out
this term so in this problem you know
what's the direction of this velocity hi
what is the unit vector associated with
the linear momentum of that pipe what
direction is the linear momentum of the
pipe
what's the velocity what is this answer
what's the momentum of that pipe mass
times that velocity right Matt remember
the velocity of the system the pipe may
have us all its mass around the rim but
the velocity of the the momentum of the
pipe is the total mass of the pipe times
the velocity of its center of mass and
that's the velocity of the center of
mass so it's linear momentum has what
unit vector signed with it
hi and what is the unit vector
associated with VA hi cross I is pink
this one of those cases where they're
parallel paths and that term drops out
so you could come up with very quickly
and easily a equation of motion okay
very good see you on Tuesday next
Tuesday lecture time will be review I
think it kind of be more like one of
these sessions and then quiz Tuesday
night